In this problem, to provide temporary support to an excavation, a temporary retaining wall is installed and braced by a diagonal brace.
The horizontal pressure acting on the wall is 30 pounds per square foot.
The length of the excavation and the wall is 10 feet, and the brace is placed in the center of the wall.
The connection of the retaining wall at the ground at point A can be represented as a hinge.
Ignoring the weight of the form, what is the axial force in pounds resisted by the brace caused by the horizontal pressure.
So the first thing that we can take away from this problem statement is that this part about the hinge actually matters.
Representing point A as a hinge converts this from a geotechnical type problem into a simple statics problem instead.
So let's draw this wall out in a little more detail just so we can understand it better.
On the exam itself, I probably would not spend time drawing this out, but obviously these practice problems are meant for you to learn.
So let's do it.
So we have the brace here and the height of the wall as 20 feet.
Recall that the brace is placed in the center of the wall and it is a 10 foot wall.
This means that there's going to be 5 feet on each side of the brace.
And as shown in the first drawing, the brace is connected to the wall at a height of 8 feet.
And then these arrows here represent the resultant force on the wall from the soil that the wall is holding back.
So the first thing we can do here is solve for the pounds per vertical foot of force that is being acted on this wall.
So step one will be 30 pounds per square foot times the 10 feet length of the wall, giving us 300 pounds per vertical foot.
So if there were 20 of these horizontal lines pushing against the wall, then there would be 300 pounds acting on each line.
Step two for us is going to be to set this problem up as a statics problem.
Since we know in statics that the resultant answer has to be 0, we can state here that the sum of the moments about point A is also 0.
So our first force is the rotational force about point A from the wall.
This will be resisted by the counter rotational force of the brace that is supporting the wall.
And those are going to cancel out.
So we can begin to extend this problem by saying 300 pounds per vertical foot times 20 feet times the force location in the rotational moment.
In this case it is going to be half the height of the wall.
And as we can see here this will give us units of pound feet.
Next we can subtract.
The height that the brace is posted to times the resultant force in the x direction provided by the brace.
Solving and simplifying this equation, we can see that our sub x is going to be equal to 7500 pounds.
For step 3 we need to find the axial load in the brace.
So let's look at our force triangle.
So in our force triangle we can see that we have 7500 pounds in the x direction.
We have a hypotenuse angle of 45 degrees of the brace respective to the ground.
And we want to find the total force that is in this brace.
So using geometry we can say that the cosine of 45 degrees equals the adjacent over the hypotenuse.
To put numbers to this the adjacent will be equal to 7500 pounds.
And the hypotenuse we can label as z.
If we solve for this we can see that z equals 10,606 pounds.
This answer is very close to the third option in our list.
It's worth mentioning that the very first answer provided here, 75003, is very close to the resultant force in the x direction.
So don't be fooled by that on the exam.
On each question it's important to make sure that you're answering the question that's actually being asked.
In our case we wanted the axial force as specified by the problem and not just the force in one direction.